Healthcare is in the midst of a digital
Revolution for mobile Health apps and
wearable devices to Telehealth and
personalized medicine digital technology
is playing an increasingly large role in
healthcare I'm Bryant Lin clinical
associate professor at Stanford
University and I'm Oliver Alami clinical
professor of vascular and endovascular
surgery at Stanford University and the
Palo Alto VA developing digital Health
Products presents many unique challenges
heightened data privacy and security
rules regulatory hurdles complex
business models involving multiple
stakeholders and long sales Cycles we
created this course to empower
Healthcare professionals to de-risk your
digital Health product development
journey through video lectures
interactive exercises and a variety of
case studies you will learn from
Stanford faculty and Industry experts
about the entire product development
process we'll show you how to identify
unmet clinical needs turn ideas into
products and bring those products to
Market
join us in our course to get a
comprehensive understanding of product
development in digital health